hey youtubers is Charlie so the Deadpool
two producers have been talking about
what's going on with the casting of
cable or they're going to be making fun
of in the sequel and they're going to be
taking shots at everybody's sequels it
is going to be open season on comic book
movies I know a lot of you are probably
asking how come there hasn't been a
whole bunch of Deadpool sequel news
there was Comic Con everybody was
dumping all their big superhero
franchise news where was Deadpool well
Fox did not go to Comic Con this year
like they've gone in past years so
that's why you didn't hear about any
Deadpool stuff but there still was
Deadpool movie stuff that was happening
there but I'll talk about that in a
second the more important stuff is that
Simon Kinberg who's also a producer on
the Deadpool movie was answering some
questions about where it was headed
what's going on with cable they're still
trying to cast him and I know a lot of
people were like Stephen Lang would be
an amazing cable but he's already come
out and said yeah they're probably not
gonna cast me they're probably gonna
cast someone that's way younger they're
not actually going to be shooting the
movie till early next year so they still
have a lot of time before they need to
cast the actor because they're still
working on the script but the thing that
they have confirmed about the script
this is actually going to seem like a
no-brainer is that the Deadpool sequel
is going to take shots at all superhero
sequels so we're not just talking about
Deadpool taking shots at the x-men
movies we're talking about Marvel we're
talking about DC Comics because it is
such rich territory you know regardless
of what you think the state of superhero
films are or how good or how bad a
certain film is there are so many shots
that you can take in all these movie
sequels I just did a Deadpool video
about how the comic book was taking
shots at the Deadpool movie
so like deadpool and spiderman go to
hollywood and they use the whole issue
to make fun of Ryan Reynolds the
Deadpool movie as well as Batman V
Superman and all the other big superhero
movies that were happening so when the
way the first movie had a lot of jokes
about the x-men movies just expect to
see a lot more about Marvel and DC
movies too there are so many easy
targets and you can just imagine there's
like an executive somewhere that's
giving notes on the film like oh you
know it's not okay to talk about this
actor or you can't reference this brand
because they're gonna sue so as much as
the first Deadpool movie was awesome
there was an executive or executive
multiple executives at Fox that signed
off on each shot they took at the other
x-men films which i think is hilarious
because normally you think of studio
executives as people that ruin movies
not make them bed
but I just can't wait to hear some of
the commentary when the second Deadpool
movie comes out like oh yeah yeah we
took all these shots at Marvel they were
totally cool with it and if you wondered
like in real life like when you hear
people talk about DC versus Marvel type
stuff the director of Suicide Squad was
actually kind of baited into saying
something bad about Marvel at the
premiere of Suicide Squad like he wasn't
being crazy or super drunk or anything
like that but there was somebody in the
crowd that said F Marvel really loud
when they were getting ready to show the
movie and he was like hell yeah brother
shouted it back at him but then
everybody reported David aired Suicide
Squad director says F Marvel so then you
just hear all of the palms hitting all
the faces all over the world and he's
like oh yeah okay so I'm sorry that was
totally not cool did not mean to say
that in like joke has thought up even
Stan Lee were like hey you know it's all
good it's totally funny we totally
understand that this was not intentional
so like everybody that works at each
different company even though they take
shots at each other harbor no grudges so
if you wonder why it's okay for Deadpool
to make fun of x-men like why the x-men
people don't get really upset about that
it's because they understand that it's
all in good fun
so let me know in the comments what's
your favorite Deadpool x-men joke from
the first film but I think my favorite
one is the one about the timelines which
professor Stewart or McAvoy so I'm
really looking forward to Deadpool
Avengers infinity war jokes Batman V
Superman Justice League jokes we'll see
how it goes down I think cable will do a
good job of balancing the film out like
Deadpool will have to be a little bit
more over the top because it's a sequel
so you're making fun of sequels Deadpool
is being a little more crazy you have to
balance that out cable is the perfect
person for that so I'm not really
expecting them to lock that down till
later this year but they'll totally make
the announcement once they find the
actor so Comic Con stuff for those of
you that went to comic-con you may have
actually spotted the director on the
floor he was giving away signed copies
of the DVD there's this picture here of
him just signing a sea of DVDs so even
though they're really quiet about what's
going on with Deadpool - there's still a
whole bunch of Deadpool movie related
stuff happening but if you're not
reading it they're a bunch of Deadpool
titles that are happening right now in
the comics they're all pretty good
spider-man and Deadpool is a little
sillier so if you're looking for like
really silly Deadpool stuff that's where
you want to go there's some Civil War
tie-ins that I'll probably check out but
you kind of pick and choose
is just based on the type of Deadpool
story that you want you know whether you
want something that's a little bit
sillier or you want something that's a
little more serious so there any other
Deadpool videos that you guys do want me
to make just let me know in the comments
be sure to subscribe to get everything
in my next video will probably be a
Suicide Squad sequel like I know we've
been talking about making fun of sequels
there will totally be Suicide Squad
sequels so I'll be posting more videos
about what I think is going to be
happening with the characters going
forward in the universe so while you
guys wait for my next video to post you
can click here for all my Suicide Squad
Easter eggs from the movie this weekend
and you can click here to watch Deadpool
just troll the crap out of Batman V
Superman thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight